♪♪
Narrator:
Welcome to Mega City.
Wh-ha-ha-hoo.!
Narrator:
Where everyday is an adventure.
Wow.
But I've never heard of that
word.
(Grasps)
You've never heard of an
adventure?
Narrator:
Oh, hi Doug.
Everyone, wave hi to Doug.
Hello.
Lady:
-Sorry, Doug.
Narrator:
I forgot, as a robot you're
not as familiar with life in Mega City.
Narrator:
I think we can help you.
Great idea.
Narrator:
Everybody, should we help Doug?
Yes!
Narrator:
Okay.
So, Doug...
Narrator:
An adventure is sort of a fun
journey you take.
Narrator:
Like walking through your town.
Or maybe going hiking.
Hiking?
-Never heard of it.
Narrator:
Well, Doug, why don't you unplug
and try it out.
Does this mean we're going on a
hike today?
I think it's time for some
good old-fashioned,
robot-father, robot-son,
robot-bonding.
(Haha)
-Oh...
-hehe.
Narrator:
And that's just one example.
Say, you and your friend, Emma,
wanted to go to the beach.
Beach? I don't know that word.
Narrator:
You'll love the beach.
There's so much to do and
discover.
Let's go mateys.
(Digging)
Ahh.
♪♪
oooh.
Narrator:
Wow. You found some great
treasures.
Narrator:
They could belong in a museum.
Oh.
Aah... What's a museum?
Narrator:
There's only one way to find
out.
No trip to the museum is
complete without exploring
an early machines exhibit.
Whoa.
All you have to do is pull on
this rope and you'll lift
something really  heavy.
Now I'm lifting me, Emma, Uncle
ForkRick, and...
Who are you?
I'm Gary.
And Gary!
Narrator:
When you're all done, you can
ride your bike home.
I have a big question.
Why do humans ride bikes?
To get that thrill when rubber
meets the road.
When rubber meets the...
You know what, you'll just have
to learn to ride a bike and see
for yourself.
Narrator:
Great idea, Emma.
Now get out there and explore.
-Whohoo.
Narrator:
Because the more questions
you ask,
Narrator:
the more adventures you'll discover.
Doug:
I can tell you're excited about
this adventure idea.
Adventures look amazing.
Unplug and follow me.
-Woo-hoo.
Woo-hoo.
Narrator:
Doug Unplugs
I learned how to have fun!
-Let's somersault...
Enjoy!
♪♪